Well, HEY THERE, you sad sack of shit!
Have you ever wanted a pet of your very own?
Well, then, why not get ROCK?!
There's SO MANY THINGS you can do with ROCK!!!!
*starts singing* You can cook with rock, give your meal some pizzazz!
You can wash your rock while you listen to jazz!
You can sit on the couch and watch some TV.
Even if what you're watching is a little sleazy!!!
You can smell all the flowers on a bright, sunny day!
You can play hide-and-seek, send your troubles away! Rock will always be there for you every day.
You can never escape how... sexy that ROCK is?!! ๏_๏
Now, I know this sounds too good to be true, but for just $10, you can have a rock of your very own!
Just go to www.markiplier.com/rock to see what rock... can do for you!
You can wash your car to make it SHINE!
You can season your rock and make it taste sublime!
But, DON'T eat your rock, whatever you do.
We're serious about this one. PLEASE DO NOT EAT THE ROCK!!!
You can drink with rock to forget your troubles!
Even though your bitch ex took your goldfish, Bubbles
and then, stomped on your dreams and tore out your heart.
But, please be aware that rock CAN'T actually talk.
*stops cheerful music- panicked talking* If rock DOES TALK, PLEASE ALERT THE SCP FOUNDATION IMMEDIATELY!!!
*Cheerful song resumes* Sleep with your rock! No, we won't judge you.
Even though you've got a pet that already loves you!
You can't deny, that rock is a little sexy!
If you wanna get freaky, then, rock is READY!!!
Brush your teeth with rock, it's as easy as pie!
If you don't brush rock every hour, you'll die!
Toss rock in the tub and cover him deep.
You know that rock's the only friend that you'll wanna keep!
Rock likes to watch you WHEN YOU SLEEP!!!
*Music Cuts out* *Warped, deep voice* RoCk Is AlSo AvAiLaBlE iN wHiTe
ωhITE!!!!
ALL these amazing features can be YOURS for only $10
YES, THIS IS REAL!!!! It is not a dream! But, your dreams have come true! Please go to www.markiplier.com/rock
and get yourself a rock today! That is markiplier.com/rock
and if you order now, I'll even throw in free shipping.